wir reden hier ja jetzt von
schwerstverbrecher
vergewaltiger genau vieles andere mehr
und selbstverständlich habe es vorhin
gesagt ich will nicht dass sie hier auf
deutschen straßen rumlaufen das heißt
die müssten wieder zurückgeführt werden
in ihr heimatland die müssen bis dahin
auch möglicherweise in abschiebehaft
genommen werden das ist machbar und wir
müssen die situation in afghanistan
natürlich genau beobachten die taliban
haben sich schon deutlich geäußert sie
wollen unterstützung finanzielle hilfe
im bereich jetzt auch der arbeit der
welthungerhilfe caritas ärzte ohne
grenzen viele sind zurzeit auch
unterwegs nach wie vor die brauchen dann
auch finanzielle unterstützung die
bundesregierung hat bereits 600
millionen euro freigegeben für die
unterstützung auch genau dieser
organisationen in afghanistan vor ort
jemand der von uns meine ich die taliban
die wahrscheinlich neue regierung in
afghanistan wenn sie unterstützung haben
will an dieser stelle dann muss man auch
darüber verhandeln dass menschen
zurückgeführt werden die hier
gewaltverbrechen begehen oder schon
gewaltverbrechen begangen haben wie
diejenigen über die wir gerade geredet
haben die sich wieder zurück nach
deutschland in irgendeiner form wie auch
immer den weg gebahnt hat